نفس التفجير على فكره
حمود قتلت الطفله وجداه نعم صحيح نفس
التفجير اعتقد في في الحي يعني سقط عليها
نتيجه تفجير سور منزلهم توفيت ايضا في في
نفس الحادث يعني استشهد العميد عبد الرحمن
الصالح محدد القيادات في اداره المرور
وكان وقتها
العقيد العميد فهد البشر كان مدير مرور
الرياض وقتها ايضا اصيب في الحادث واجريت
عمليات سريعه يعني تعافى في خلال الايام
فبالتالي وهناك يعني في هذا الحادث سقط
اعتقد تسعه يعني قتله او سبعه قتله اصيب
العشرات يعني اكثر من مئه طبعا كان
التفجير حتى وقت التفجير كان
يعني تم اختيار بعنايه من التنظيم
الارهابي كانت الساعه 2:00 ظهرا يعني في
الدروه الدروه في خروج المو الحركه ايضا
تكون في ذلك الوقت في المناطق المحيطه
تكون في يعني سواء الخارجين من الاعمال او
المدارس بالضبط
بالتالي التنظيم الارهابي مختار الوقت
بعنايه وهي سياره جي ام سي يعني مليئه
بالمتفجرات
تم محاوله اقتحام البوابه
منعوا من الحرس
ركنها على بعد امتار ثم فجرها وبالتالي
كان هناك طبعا عنصرين من
العنصر الارهابيه ونفدت عمليه وكانوا
مسجلين